Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Voi volete cambiare il mondo, vero?
Tutti vogliamo cambiare il mondo.
Ma quante volte ci hanno ripetuto
che per cambiare il mondo
ci vuole una nuova tecnologia,
una nuova applicazione,
una nuova piattaforma digitale.
Stasera proveremo a sfidare
quella che chiamo
retorica dell'innovazione,
con tre piccole, semplici idee.
La prima: l'idea che l'innovazione
sia sempre un processo collettivo.
Tutti i partecipiamo all'innovazione, no?
Dobbiamo uscire
da questa idea dell'inventore,
della persona chiusa
nel proprio laboratorio.
Tutti, come utilizzatori, contribuiamo
all'affermazione di un'innovazione.
L'innovazione è qualcosa di più,
e di diverso, di nuova tecnologia.
Non sono sinonimi, le due cose.
L'innovazione non è l'invenzione.
Ogni giorno, potenzialmente,
ci sono milioni di nuove idee,
di nuove invenzioni.
Cos'è un'innovazione?
L'innovazione è un modo diverso
di fare le cose che si afferma,
è un'invenzione che si fa carne.
È un nuovo modo di fare le cose
che incontra un altro cambiamento.
Ci fa vedere dei bisogni
che non sapevamo neanche di avere.
Quindi è un momento
di cambiamento sociale e culturale.
Torniamo un po' indietro nel tempo.
Siamo a metà '800, 1847.
Un medico di origine ungherese
arriva a Vienna,
alla clinica "Allgemeinen Krankenhaus",
per il primo incarico importante.
Arrivando da fuori,
rimane colpito da qualcosa
a cui probabilmente
i colleghi più esperti,
che erano lì da più tempo,
si erano assuefatti.
Ed era una cosa drammatica, inaccettabile:
il tasso di morti tra le partorienti,
che andava dal 13 al 30 percento.
Quasi una su tre moriva.
Sul perché questo avvenisse,
nessuno aveva una spiegazione.
Si parlava dello stress,
della situazione del parto addirittura,
dell'inquinamento.
C'era una serie di ipotesi,
nessuna delle quali convinceva
questo giovane medico,
che si chiamava Ignác Semmelweis.
Un giorno, cosa avviene?
Avviene che un collega,
praticando un'autopsia, si ferisce
e muore a seguito di questa ferita.
Allora Semmelweis
va a vedere meglio i dati,
e scopre che nei padiglioni dell'ospedale
dove gli stessi medici
praticano le autopsie
e poi assistono ai parti,
i tassi di morti sono molto più elevati.
Allora comincia una sua battaglia,
per imporre che cosa?
Un'innovazione a bassissima tecnologia:
il lavaggio delle mani, la disinfezione
con una soluzione a base di cloro.
Incontra, sembra incredibile,
una grandissima ostilità
da parte dei colleghi:
come si permette questo, appena arrivato,
di dire che siamo noi, i salvatori,
che portiamo la morte?
Perché lui stava dicendo questo.
Alla fine, vincerà la sua battaglia:
i tassi di morte tra le partorienti
cominceranno immediatamente a scendere.
Un piccolo gesto ha quindi salvato
la vita di milioni di persone -
tranne, purtroppo,
quella dello stesso innovatore.
Perché Semmelweis da questa battaglia
alla fine uscirà personalmente sconfitto:
non gli sarà neppure
rinnovato il contratto,
e terminerà la propria vita
in un ospedale psichiatrico.
Si può cambiare il mondo anche osservando
in modo diverso la natura,
qualcosa che abbiamo
sotto gli occhi quotidianamente.
Siamo attorno al 1870:
è l'America che abbiamo visto
in tanti film western.
È un paese che si sta espandendo
rapidamente verso ovest.
Ma tra i tanti problemi,
tra le tante sfide,
ce n'è una molto concreta:
la protezione del bestiame.
Il bestiame, naturalmente,
tende a spostarsi,
viene rubato, viene portato via.
Come si fa a delimitarlo?
Si costruiscono palizzate:
ma bisogna continuamente
ripararle, sostituirle.
E costa tantissimo.
Qualcuno scopre che si può utilizzare
un arbusto, si chiama Maclura,
che ha le caratteristiche
per proteggere naturalmente,
per impedire che il bestiame si allontani.
Ma naturalmente, un arbusto ha dei limiti:
tende a crescere dove vuole,
e attira gli insetti.
Allora, ecco l'osservazione che fanno
un commerciante e un agricoltore:
si può fare una Maclura artificiale,
si può fare un filo metallico
intervallato da punte regolari.
È uno dei brevetti più semplici,
ma dal maggiore impatto
nella storia dell'umanità.
Sono 13 parole.
È il filo spinato brevettato nel 1873.
Naturalmente, come tutte le innovazioni,
anche questa è una bella lezione, no?
Ha un impatto straordinario positivo:
gli Stati Uniti non sarebbero divenuti
la nazione che sono divenuti,
senza questa piccola grande innovazione;
ma naturalmente ha un lato B,
un lato drammatico,
che saranno le trincee,
i campi di concentramento
e tutto ciò che il filo
spinato rappresenterà,
soprattutto nel secolo successivo.
Negli anni '70 un ingegnere giapponese,
Eiji Nakatsu, deve risolvere un problema.
Quando un ingegnere giapponese
viene incaricato di risolvere un problema,
lo deve risolvere davvero.
Il problema è questo:
il treno, uno dei primi treni
ad alta velocità, lo Shinkansen,
quando entra ed esce dalle gallerie,
provoca uno sconquasso sonoro,
un inquinamento acustico,
che provoca disturbo
in un raggio molto ampio.
Nakatsu capisce che è un problema
di diversa resistenza dell'aria,
fuori e dentro la galleria.
Allora si chiede,
cosa che naturalmente non è da tutti:
"C'è un animale
che ha risolto questo problema
del passaggio da due
densità diverse dell'aria?"
C'era: era il martin pescatore.
Il martin pescatore,
per catturare la propria preda,
deve passare dall'aria,
quindi da una certa resistenza,
all'acqua,
senza provocare troppo schizzo
per non allertare la preda.
Soluzione di Nakatsu, che immediatamente
risolve o attenua il problema:
costruzione, dotazione di un "becco"
molto simile a quello
del martin pescatore,
per lo Shinkansen.
Di queste ve ne potrei
raccontare molte altre.
Una è il velcro, per esempio.
Nasce anche questo
dall'osservazione della bardana,
di come si attaccavano questi -
al pelo del cane
di colui che l'ha inventato.
Si può cambiare il mondo
anche mettendo insieme due cose
che apparentemente non hanno
nulla a che fare tra di loro.
Il problema che questo
futuro innovatore voleva affrontare
era quello della preparazione del caffè.
Siamo negli anni '30 del '900.
La preparazione del caffè a casa
era una faccenda piuttosto complicata,
perché questa caffettiera,
la caffettiera napoletana,
tra le altre cose,
al termine della preparazione
andava rovesciata.
E quindi, si creavano
tutta una serie di problemi.
Non era esattamente semplice e piacevole.
Lui aveva osservato - abitava a Omegna -
che le massaie,
non avendo l'acqua corrente,
tantomeno calda, a casa,
utilizzavano per lavare i panni
un mastello col fondo bucato
e mettevano questa miscela
di cenere e sapone
sul fondo del mastello.
L'acqua calda la faceva bollire.
Allora si chiede: si può applicare
questo procedimento di percolazione...
alla preparazione del caffè?
La risposta è sì:
e l'innovazione che ne viene fuori -
si chiamava Alfonso Bialetti -
è la moka, brevettata nel 1933.
La scelta del nome è molto felice:
uno dei crocevia commerciali del caffè
è la città di Moka nello Yemen.
La scelta del materiale è molto felice:
l'alluminio, materiale elegante ma poroso,
quindi più caffè si fanno,
più il caffè nella moka diventa buono.
Poi, anche la scoperta per cui entra
in tutte le case degli italiani,
della potenza della
comunicazione pubblicitaria.
Ultimo esempio: lo sport.
Lo sport è un terreno meraviglioso
per osservare l'innovazione
dal punto di vista in cui
vi sto suggerendo di guardarla.
Siamo nel 1968, Olimpiadi
di Città del Messico.
Questo ragazzo si chiama Richard.
Richard si è dato al salto in alto,
ma non aveva il fisico adatto
per saltare come si usava all'epoca,
cioè saltare con lo stile ventrale,
affrontando l'asticella frontalmente.
Allora, lui cosa fa?
Siccome a un certo punto
non ce la fa più, dice:
Io lo faccio al contrario.
Contro il parere del suo allenatore,
che dice: "Ti farai male, sei pazzo!"
Lui però è anche fortunato -
a volte, gli innovatori sono fortunati:
proprio in quegli anni,
vengono introdotti
i materassi per l'atterraggio.
Atterrando sulla sabbia, naturalmente,
si sarebbe fatto molto più male.
Insomma, dai e dai,
perfeziona il suo stile,
e si qualifica per il rotto della cuffia
alla finale olimpica a Città del Messico.
Adesso vediamo - sarete curiosi -
forse sapete com'è andata a finire.
(Video)
Anche qui, non c'è
nessuna nuova tecnologia:
ma c'è un modo completamente
diverso di fare le cose,
quello che si chiama
un cambio di paradigma.
Fosbury si è fatto la domanda
che chiunque voglia cambiare
il mondo dovrebbe farsi:
perché tutti fanno così?
Bisogna fare così come tutti gli altri,
o si può fare in modo diverso?
Quindi, scherzosamente, si potrebbe dire
che ci ha spiegato, ci ha fatto capire,
che a volte, per andare avanti,
bisogna andare un pochino indietro.
Poi, in generale, non dimentichiamoci
che a volte, per cambiare il mondo,
è possibile cambiare il mondo
guardando le cose in modo diverso
da come le avevamo viste
fino a quel momento.
Grazie.
(Applausi)